I am real I'm a pasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make offense for first another
announcement we got more March a lot of
people were asking for us to make
something warmer for winter so we made a
Fisher if you want to check out the link
in description let's see what we are
making fancy today frozen french fries
my favorite fast food restaurant eat
Shake Shack they use frozen french fries
so this is pretty rare for this show
I've tried frozen french fries I must
say this is not too bad if you're making
french fries from scratch you have to
cut the potato you have to double fry
them this is such a good invention I
think shout out to whoever invented this
I hope you're rich french fry it's very
cultural so it's a little bit difficult
to elevate I just want to add something
more rich okay I've got a great idea and
actually I think this thing it's easy to
make a home so I'm very excited to make
it fancy guess what I got
chives heavy cream butter garlic truffle
butter cheese cars and lobster tails
from the pantry I got black pepper salt
flour chicken stock white wine and
brandy double alcohol today let's get
started make you fancy first I'm going
to need 2 cloves of garlic
set aside full tablespoon of truffle
butter if you don't have a budget buying
truffle butter you just see it's better
but this show is make you fancy
completely melt this truffle butter in a
medium heat butter it's completely
melted so I'm going to grate garlic with
microplane I'm going to make sauce and I
don't want chunk of garlic when you're
eating
if you don't have micro praying you can
just chop the garlic very finely quarter
cup flour and just whisk it you want to
cook flour two to three minutes
otherwise the sauce tastes like flour
and you don't want it major wine when
you're cooking flour and the butter
mixture you also want to constantly
whisk it so it doesn't become a lumpy
I like using alcohol yes but I never
said like drinking alcohol just wanted
to be clear on that
I made a roux with flour and butter and
kind of singing outreach twine and one
cup and half chicken stock you have to
add little by little otherwise the sauce
gonna be seized up you also have to
constantly whiskey so I made a bow in
this show that I'm going to drive on a
highway in 2020 new year just had
started I still have the liver mustard
all my inspiration for this sauce is
kind of like bechamel it's more like a
gravy this is a little bit runny a sauce
so you will core ingredients nicely
1/2 cup of heavy cream
make sure heavy cream is room
temperature if you are going to use a
cold heavy cream sauce is going to
separate so it's same as chicken stock
you want to add cream little bit at all
salt to taste black pepper when you're
making classic bechamel I think instead
of using black pepper about cayenne
pepper so you don't see like flick about
this is gravy so the indicator of if the
sauce is ready or now you kind of use
spatula and run through this suck up the
spoon and if the line is straight nor
spreading out it's ready I'm going to
set aside and moving to the next step -
lobster tails previously frozen and now
it's fold cook in a boiler water until
the color turns red lobster it's not
insect of the seat
lobsters lobsters oh really
[Music]
what so it's kind of like people just
made it up lobster it's fancy
so lobster it's red I'm going to remove
from the pot we are going to cook it
later so let this cool for 10 to 15
minutes and I'm going to move on to next
step
frozen french fry time i heated oil to
375 you don't want to put all at once
because it will lower the oil
temperature when you're making french
fry from scratch what you have to do is
you fry the potato with lower
temperature first so it cooks through
and then you raise the temperature and
cook again so it's crunchy takes a lot
of time and love if you buy frozen
french fries they are precooked so you
can bake in oven but I like crispy
texture so I'm frying instead of baking
fry them to golden-brown when you just
put throw the french fry day it's like
big bubbles around there so when you're
close to get done big bubble gets a
little bit smaller and tinier also there
is a sound cue when you just put
uncooked food it's not only french fry
like fried chicken
it sounds like heavy rain but when it's
ready
it sounds like sprinkle of water so it's
golden brown I'm taking off french fries
from the pot and kind of spread it out
so it doesn't get soggy you also want to
season with salt when it's still hot so
salt kind of get inside of the potato
okay
so I'm going to fry another batch of
frozen french fries and move them to the
next step a lobster is cool to the touch
I'm going to remove the shell it's kind
of made a sound yeah it's it's just it's
not like crack it open a little
difficult too
Haeckel to me but we're gonna chop their
anyways cut into little pieces
we do have lobster ninja fights also
expensive ingredients so lobster is cut
into bite-size put a little bit
flavoring two tablespoon of butter
why did butter is melting I'm going to
measure and I think we dance the quarter
cup double alcohol odd up stir right
long time lumber country Colombia it's
Barney alcohol was fire it's gone most
of the alkaloids also gone to so we also
made a nice kind of butter brandy sauce
it is ready I'm going to set aside and
move on to the next step
most those ingredients ready we have
french fries cook the lobster and gravy
and I'm going to chop some garnish you
can do from bay or you don't need to do
it if you are a little bit intimidated
you don't need to use brandy you can
just saute lobster we its butter it's
actually very tasty as its I added
brandy because you know me french fried
cheese part so you kind of want to
sprinkle everywhere I kind of want to
put inside so you had like surprise
cheese card and my gravy I just reheated
so it's nice and warm and make sure
gravy it's hot so cheese got it's kind
of nice and melty and also I'd like to
use room-temperature cheese curd so it
melts better and love starts
I like this blondie and butter sauce so
I want to make sure it's the old to
choose Treasury cracked black pepper to
add some about flavor right we are done
[Music]
hey guys I'm Carl and this is tasties
making it big no need to make you funky
it's not make it back thank you
it's not big can you guess what I made
fancy this time looks like french fries
kind of okay that's pretty good cheese
chives maybe like a seafood poutine no
yes
lobster poutine Carlos smart Carl it's
like Carl you know foxy has an album
Carl is indeed fancier than Alvin
because Alvin needs to do laundry we
knew that with this one shirt I could
finally achieve my dreams of being fancy
okay digging Carl all right here we go
wow it's a big fight I'm big boy that's
true mmm
[Music]
thank you I don't pay money for that
restaurant then give me money does it
make you feel fancy yeah I feel very
fancy wearing this t-shirt uh-huh who's
who I'm a fancy man you know I think
this is your best one yet last time you
didn't do things correctly I assume you
know practice a home yeah Alvin higher
thank you make it fancy
welcome Chris to make it fancy thank you
yeah
Gracie its new tasty producer he is from
Chris ow you said it right yes I
practiced and he can speak five
different languages for and he's very
well Driftless I agree look how fuzzy he
is big bite hmm there's just an
explosion of fancy know what it is can
you teach me how to say make you fancy
in Spanish hacerlo lujo so I said hola
and Dutch market looks like a couch
laughs I your native language elementary
hacia lujo hassium make it fancy
[Music]